it is across the US have erupted enraged
shops have been looted cars and
buildings taught poor in response to the
death of George Floyd while in police
custody and mothers protesting are very
clear about why they are on the streets
justice equality and end to police
brutality others aren't convinced that
that really is the fuel behind this fire
if it is white supremacist if it is
Russian if it is other foreign actors
who've tried to exploit the paint they
should be arrested and prosecuted as
well well I didn't see that one coming
Russians might have a hand in all of
this apparently an argument the mayor of
Minneapolis the site of the crime at the
crux of the anger wasted no time in
seizing on we are now confronting white
supremacists members of organized crime
out of state instigators and possibly
even foreign actors to destroy and
destabilize our city and our region so
to clarify Russians white supremacist
drug cartels Regis any foreigners have
all been waiting for a policeman in
Minnesota to allegedly kill an unarmed
African American man so that finally
they can put that devious plan to divide
the United States of America into action
seems like a bit of a long game but sure
many excuse to detract from the long
hair institutional racism and excessive
violence of the police force and you
know the drill
once the conspiracy is out there there's
no shortage of media pundits to spin it
out based on my experience this is right
out of the Russian playbook as well but
we can't allow the extremists the
foreign actors to distract from the real
problems we have in this country that
are long-standing centuries old and need
to be addressed responsibly by new
leadership but there appear to be some
who have learnt from the Russia Gate
debacle and decided not to hitch a ride
on this particular conspiracy
you know CNN
said that Russia might be behind some of
the rioting and the acts of violence and
destruction and I I don't know that I'd
go so far to say that it's Russia's
fault but I would say most of the
peaceful folks I'm seeing are my
community members these are the folks
that live here in the woods animate
we're out here demanding change you know
people are dying in our streets black
men are being killed by police and that
protest is real I think any news that's
taking away from the real issue here
it's just a distraction it's trying to
to take the gas out of our tank to get
positive change for the people like
people this is my community this isn't
Russia but the conspirators on Twitter
won't matter a skeptical voice or to
dampen their spirits as Americans think
about race and policing it's important
to keep in mind that adversaries like
Russia will stoke tension and create
division among us Russia feeds on our
chaos this is what you won't see on the
news black protestors protecting a white
officer who was separated from his unit
don't let them divide us
we can beat racism together only
together divided Russia wins
so the fury coursing through America at
the moment is being stoked by the
Kremlin and not by centuries of racial
tensions in which peace may be slavery
maybe segregation maybe NFL pairs
kneeling during the singing of the
national anthem are also Russia's doing
surely that comes a point when you have
to stop pointing fingers and just face
the ugly truth in the mirror
you